دكتور صلاح الدين ما تكلفه ما يحدث الان
في السودان
ما هو الثمن الذي سيدفعه السودان دوله
وشعبا باستمرار هذه المواجهه
وهذه المواجهه التي اندلعت امس جزء من
المشهد المربك الذي ظل السوداني يعيشه
ودفعت ثمنا غاليا في
حياه الناس وفي معاشهم في الاوضاع التي
تتدهور يوما بعد يوم سودان بلد غني وثري
وامامه فرص كبيره جدا جدا خصوصا في ظل
التحولات العالميه اليوم ولكن غياب
القياده وغياب الطبقه السياسيه الواعيه
المتماسكه ليس فقط بددت الفرصه التي كان
يمكن للسودان ان ينتهزها بل حولت هذه
الفرصه الى نقمه لان جعلت الاطراف
المتصارعه الان دوليا واقليميا تصبح جزء
من تعقيدات المشهد السوداني فالسودان فقد
كثير جدا جدا في ظل كل هذه الاوضاع
المعركه اليوم التي تدور والمواجهات كلما
حسمت باسرع ما يمكن كان افضل لانه استمرار
كما ذكرت الان الملايين السوداني مروعين
في بيوتهم لا يستطيعون ان يخرجون الاطفال
احنا البارحه تابعه الاطفال محجوزين في
المدارس يوم كامل لا يستطيعون يذهبون الى
اسرهم هنالك ارواح
سقطت هنالك جرحه هنالك تدمير هنالك اذا
استمرت لا سمح الله قد يؤسس لصراعات على
اسس عرقيه او جهويه او الى ذلك ولذلك
السودان يواجه مازق شديد جدا لابد من
الانتباه لانه هذه المعارك التي تدور
الكل يتمنى انها لم تندلع ولكن طالما
اندال عاد يجب ان تقف باسرع ما يمكن ان
تحلل مشكله حلا جذريا يعني ليست حلول التي
تبقي على المشاكل لتنفجر في لحظه اخرى
يعني لا بد من حلول جزريه للمشاكل التي
ادت لان السودان لا يتحمل ان تنفجر هذه
المشاكل في لحظات اخرى وتؤدي لنفس النتائج
الان يعني طريقه دكتور صلاح الدين الزين